[Music]
welcome to your weekly ticket sponsored
by trolley
good news everyone george miller's
highly anticipated mad max fury road
prequel has begun filming chris
hemsworth shared the news on twitter
writing a new journey and the mad max
saga begins the spin-off prequel titled
furiosa is centered on charlize theron's
furiosa character and will feature the
northmen star anya taylor joy in the
lead role miller who is co-writing and
directing the movie for warner brothers
teased that while fury road happened
over three days and two nights this film
will take place over many years sony
pictures next spider-man villain
spin-off madame webb has assembled an
all-star cast the movie which is the
first female-led film to be developed
within the sony pictures universe of
marvel characters has tapped dakota
johnson sydney sweeney isabella merced
and celeste o'connor to star
the film directed by sj clarkson will be
an origin story of the clairvoyant web
whose psychic abilities allow her to see
within the spider worlds and it was
revealed that before production wrapped
daniela melchior reunited with james
gunn on guardians of the galaxy vol 3.
the suicide squad breakout star will
have a small role in the film but will
not be playing moon dragon as previously
speculated volume 3 brings back chris
pratt as star lord dave bautista as drax
palm clem and tf as mantis bradley
cooper as the voice of rocket raccoon
and vin diesel as the voice of groot
joining melchior as a guardian newbie
will be will poulter as adam warlock
they're back dinosaurs are now on the
mainland this weekend's big theatrical
release is the long-awaited jurassic
world dominion
four years after the destruction of isla
nublar which was the theme park home of
jurassic world dinosaurs now live and
hunt alongside humans all over the world
this fragile balance will reshape the
future and determine once and for all
whether human beings are to remain the
apex predators on a planet they now
share with history's most fearsome
creatures in a new era
colin trevaro directs the sixth entry in
the jurassic franchise
the first with all the main characters
from the first and second franchise
trilogy
dinosaurs aren't the only behemoths
brought back in dominion the third
jurassic world film also brings back the
original trio of scientists from the
beloved 1993 classic jurassic park
in a reunion 29 years in the making
paleontologist dr alan grant and dr
ellie sattler played by samuel and laura
dern and mathematician dr ian malcolm
played by jeff goldblum all return
fandango correspondent nikki novak
recently sat down with the legacy actors
to talk about what it's like to reunite
and what's changed in the franchise
since they all started i remember
colin
you know being in the direction of the
scene
and then saying it hit him
that our characters were there
all together again and that he got
moved
and we um i texted uh stephen a
photograph
of all of us together what'd you say he
got very emotional he said he said it
made him uh yeah
yeah so it is yeah a lovely family story
i know you said back in the day sam that
you all became the masters of amazement
because you were the first to do a
blockbuster cg film and you had to react
off of something off of just whatever it
was
have you perfected it reperfected it who
amongst the three of you is the biggest
master of amazement and coming back this
time how different
did it feel did it feel sort of like the
last time or does it feel completely
like something new um there's nothing
like the first time is there
when it comes when it comes to ore and
you know that stuff i'd nominate laura
dern as being the number one just for
shock and awe i second that emotion yeah
oh there's nobody nobody can do that i
will say that
i will say
that
being the original cast
putting ourselves in circumstances where
then friends would ask us what was that
like you had nothing to look at and now
every actor we know has had to do this
in a movie
um but we felt like we were the first
ones you know pretending at something
that wasn't there and then walking onto
a set with other people have who've been
doing this for three movies oh yeah and
watching bryce also
scream in her shock and awe
i don't know she might have taken the
cake novak also sat down with the new
trilogy cast where bryce dallas howard
and chris pratt shared their reaction to
seeing dominion for the first time
epic is the word
yeah and it's i mean this is the sixth
jurassic park movie and
it's the first where all of us are in it
together and so if that's not epic like
what is scale of one to 100
epicness oh it's it's in the high
hundreds
it's it's a triple digits
on only just one just to 100 yeah 160.
yeah that's pretty good no it it is it's
the scope is unlike anything you've ever
seen in one of these films i mean you'll
see
as the rest of the world is seeing at
the same time uh
and you know god willing in theaters uh
it's it's it's massive and you've got
jeff goldblum and sam neil and laura
dern all back you've got a bunch of
amazing new characters you've got uh
claire and owen and dinosaurs you've
never seen before and truly colin has
done just a masterful job it does truly
feel like this franchise has been not
just 65 million years in the making but
65 million and 30 years in the making
okay we're done that was it that was
great yeah
that was perfect and straight from the
source we got the intel on the new
characters ramsay cole played by mamudu
athey and kayla watts played by dewanda
wise
dewand and mamadou new characters coming
into this what can you tell us about
each of who you play
well yeah i play this uh bioson
executive ramsay cole highly driven
highly motivated and i i was telling
colin earlier i wish i could be like him
in real life um just this hyper-focused
uh mission-oriented guy that you know
just has his eye on the ball every time
well kayla is the best
a little bit about the character what's
the deal with kayla uh the deal with
kayla kayla kayla watts is former u.s
air force
uh so she has like this wonderful kind
of thread with owen and that former like
military background and when you first
meet her it's very clear she's like
absolutely fine and not only fine but
like super happy on her own so um she's
a voyeur she's an adventurer she's super
scrappy you know she's like early career
harrison ford and i love her so much
[Laughter]
did i get a hat no i got gloves oh yes
she did
[Laughter]
go jurassic this summer with your
favorite movie candies by three
participating items and get a five
dollar movie reward to be entered for a
chance to win a dino's weight in candy
see the link in the description of the
video for offer details and terms and
conditions
[Music]
and available to watch at home this
weekend is downton abbey a new era and
the unbearable weight of massive talent
years ago
before you were born
i
met a man
and now i've come into the possession of
a villa in the south of france what the
story of the crawley family while the
owners of a large estate in the english
countryside in the early 20th century
continues in downton abbey a new era
julian fellowes the oscar-winning
screenwriter and the creator of the
original series scripts a new era the
follow-up to the 2019 feature film in
which the crawley family and downton
staff receive a royal visit from the
king and queen of great britain maggie
smith elizabeth mcgovern and hugh
bonneville return as the crawlies among
many other familiar faces joining the
cast are hugh dancy laura haddick
natalie bay dominic west and jonathan
zakai
well that's it for this week i'm kale
and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you